because like you never really think
about something like stroke order you
know animal which stroke order is
basically order
you've write it in yeah cause like I
write my asses the wrong way in English
and people freaking tell people how you
write your asses ah I pushed it from top
to bottom
yeah most people do well yeah I do from
the bottom up
yeah like swish down with the cursive I
know why I'm like like how did you love
that I I I was like I was so bad at
English in school so to clarify right
like okay I'll just I'll just start the
story with this we'll start strong right
I was so bad at English that they like
put me with the kids who you know were
not good at anything you know like yeah
yeah yeah with I was in like the English
class for one year with like kids with
learning disabilities yeah right and I
remember being like dude what the [ __ ]
okay like I've always been like really
good at most subjects in school and okay
to clarify the reason why my English was
so bad and is the only reading and
writing I ever did was in Welsh my
schools watch today or everything I I
spoke in school and read was in watch
but I also knew how to spell English I
speak English obviously and then yeah I
remember we did like an English spelling
test
I got like everything wrong but bare
mind I was like eight and I couldn't I
remember they said like aw can you spell
the word said for us I was like yeah
sure and I'd you put like a CD but like
yeah like Zed Edie yeah and then there
and then my parents like oh no mind like
I never read anything in English the
reading it all over she's always
videogames so so yeah and I've got was
like why did this story come up I forgot
why I was saying this this is weird yeah
so I think I learned how to write
because in English is well they they in
school they teach you the stroke order I
just I can't remember this I mean I I
learnt it when we had to I don't know if
this is only in Australia but like yeah
I think I was in like fourth grade also
I should have those papers which are
half-width and forward yeah yeah I I
learned how to do when we want to write
cursive
yeah cuz we've already incur Civ and it
kind of became thing where for some
reason I just started writing some of
them weirdly and no one ever stopped me
and so I wanna so I just I've always
done like I'll go into like the a and
I'll go down and then do the s up and
then slash down how do you write your
like the number 5 do you go from the
bottom or do you from the top it depends
I guess like whatever the what if it
depends yeah I don't know like sometimes
how does that work that's how I would do
it from the top but I remember
distinctly I was doing it from the
bottom for a while and then I stopped
that but I also used to write my fours
like the correct waiting for wait do you
how do you learn right for us I do I do
it this way I do it that's the way I
learned but then I remember I was
playing brain training and they wouldn't
accept that way of writing forth this is
when I was like 11 so then I started
having to write force in the
Americanized way which is doing that way
and then like that
that's the Americanized way well it's
well I think so yeah well you do like if
looks like I'd like a kind of like spiky
9 right I don't think I write any
letters starting from the bottom no no
I'm like always
how would you do your force for like
this oh yeah I do it the opposite way I
think yeah yeah so you do from the
bottom yeah from the bottom and then I
go what do you do that